dans la salle des festins du palais
aujourd'hui david myriam a posé son
matériel dans un instant l'artiste va
jouer du sable sa spécialité
j'ai commencé par faire des films
d'animation avec le sable et comme voilà
ça se faisait aussi respectable et je me
suis mis aussi en 2005
moi j'aimerais bien te raconter les
choses
déjà choisi un peu de la bd j'aime bien
le cinéma donc placé un peu un mélange
entre arts plastiques cinéma bd c'est un
mélange de tout ça en fait ce qu'elle
peut au départ il n'y a rien juste un
rectangle de lumière comme une page
blanche
ensuite arrive le sable des petits
nuages des vagues
les grains s'organisent les mains les
doigts de david myriam les anime
il se met à raconter des histoires des
grains de sable qui dansent comme des
mots chanteuse un poème comme fois la
série il faut faut s'adapter
c'est plus seul ce qu'ils font ne sait
plus l'ambiance le le mouvement que
confère un tableau pendant trois heures
est très pressé blanc large plan moyen
plans serrés le spectateur voyage dans
l'univers de l'artiste
un dessin animé de sable en direct un
joli voyage à travers le monde éphémère
comme un vrai changement climatique la
destruction des forêts et sauf après
sinon c'est des choses plus poétique
aussi comme là aujourd'hui
un spectacle sur des animaux dave du
végétal la lune et où salon placé plus
haut dans le rêve un peu voilà
magnifique original en fait on découvre
au fur et à mesure ce qui dessine et
puis les enfants se questionner pareil
au fur et à mesure sur ce qui apparaît
c'est ma j'ai tout aimé
on n'a pas envie qu'il efface en fait on
est subjugué par le désert là moi les
touareg c'est impressionnant à la fin
chacun rêve de pouvoir en faire autant
et demain